i'm 6'3 i'm a big [ __ ]  okay okay no no no no no no this is what  we're gonna change it to okay oh excuse  me  so gabby what are we gonna see today  some history [ __ ]  no  no  no no no no no it's like we don't assume  they did it on purpose  we assume it was an accident we assumed  the best  like oh excuse me  for you and instead of saying excuse the  [ __ ] me [ __ ] i says i says excuse the  frick me  female dog  no no no  we just that might rub people the wrong  way right we're trying to assume that  but we're not trying to search  we're trying to avoid conflict okay  because what what good is that we're  avoiding conflict yeah so we can say oh  excuse me yeah excuse me yeah not excuse  you [ __ ]